in that process of having you know lost
all of that weight
i definitely really contributed towards
me getting my mind right adele opens up
about losing 100 pounds
the grammy winner got candid about her
health journey during her sit-down
interview with oprah winfrey during
sunday's cbs special adele one night
only explaining that she started to lose
weight about two years ago when she
realized that working out with her
trainer helped her keep her anxiety
attacks at bay i had the most terrifying
anxiety attacks after i left my marriage
they'd paralyzed me completely and
i started to notice a how much i trusted
my trainer and his like presence when i
was feeling so lost but also that i
didn't have any anxiety when i was with
him at the gym so then i picked up every
day and then i had nothing else to do
and i think
it was just it became my time me having
a plan every day when i had no plans i
had no idea what each day was going to
bring for me but me knowing that okay at
9am i'm gonna go to the gym okay great
well that gives me some discipline okay
1pm i'm going to go for a hike you know
having these sort of pins in my day
helped me keep myself you weren't even
starting out trying to lose weight as
for all the attention she's received
over her physical transformation she
said she knew it would be a hot topic of
discussion
i'm not shocked or even phased by it
because my body has been objectified my
entire career of course adele shocked
fans back in 2020 when she posted this
pic to instagram on her 32nd birthday
rocking a little black dress the pic has
more than 12 million likes and almost a
quarter million comments mostly about
her physique it looks really amazing and
while the public's reaction to adele's
weight loss has been mixed the hello
singer says she can't take that on it's
not my job to validate how people feel
about their bodies
and i feel bad that you know it's made
anyone feel
horrible about themselves
but that's not my job and i i can't
i'm trying to sort my own life out you
know i can't
i can't add another worry and another
thing to try and nail i can't back in
october adele opened up about the
response to her new look during an
interview with vogue admitting that a
lot of the chatter was hurtful i don't
even know why to be honest i don't get
it quote i understand why it's a shock i
understand why some women especially
were hurt visually i represented a lot
of women but i'm still the same person
and the worst part of the whole thing
was that the most brutal conversations
were being had by other women about my
body i was very disappointed with that
that hurt my feelings but adele said she
wants her fans to know this body
positivity comes in all shapes and sizes
quote you don't need to be overweight to
be body positive you can be any shape or
size i was body positive then and i'm
body positive now now adele says she's
not worried about her weight fluctuating
she says she fancies herself an athlete
and calls lifting weights her favorite
what's the highest weight you can press
now last summer when i was at my i was
at my peak of being able to like i could
have in the olympics on a deadlift we
were getting up to like 160 170
yeah i love it but it started out at 10
pounds i should have been an athlete if
only at school i hadn't discovered boys
and someone had told me to go and do a
bit more pe i'm also a very good boxer
i've got a left hook that could kill you
of course adele's vocal performance
during the two-hour special could kill
us too
[Music]
and she looked every bit the mega star
in this floor-length black gown nobody
has a voice like hers nobody
nobody and she did not disappoint e.t
recently caught up with gayle king who
attended the taping of one night only
and the cbs morning's anchor was
literally all of us after watching
sunday's special she just looked so good
the dress she was wearing made me think
i'm going to give up eating cupcakes
until the next day
as for adele's internal transformation
she said she's just focused on loving
herself i don't have to expect someone
else to give me stability i can also be
stable for myself
be a solid house that doesn't blow over
in a storm